THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANT AT ARMS OF PREPARE
THE CHAMBER IN BRINGING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA AND WE ARE CURRY ALLEN
IRAN BELA. BAKER BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM.
BONTA.
BRAVO.
BURKE. CABALLERO CALDERONE
CORREO SURVIVED HAS CHILD CHAVEZ
CHEN. DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY. COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALLY.
DALY. EGGMAN.
LARA. FONG.
FRAZIER FREEDMAN.
GALLAGHER CHRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA. GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GRAY. GRAYSON
HARPER.
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
CHOLERA.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE ME MOAN.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA. MELENDEZ
MULLIN MASUCCI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA RAY IS
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SOLACE
SANTIAGO STEINORTH STONE. THEIR
MEN'S.
TING BOTH PAL. WALDRON WEBER.
WOULD MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASKED OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS.
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY.
SUE PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
DAIS PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND BOB WELSH
TO. RIVER NEXT.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
AS WE BEGIN THE FOURTH DAY OF
THE NEW YEAR.
I FOUND THAT I AM STILL QUIETLY
TRYING TO PROCESS
THE EVENTS OF THE PAST YEAR.
WE HAVE LIVED THROUGH MUCH IN
THE CLOSING MONTHS ALONE.
TRAGEDIES CAUSED BY NATURE.
AND THOSE PERPETRATED BY
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
SENSE OF HUMANITY.
HAVE COLLECTIVELY MADE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
A YEAR WITH MORE THAN ITS FULL
MEASURE OF PAIN SADNESS AND
LOSS.
WE CANNOT HELP BUT WONDER.
WHAT CHANGES WITH THE NEW YEAR
AHEAD HAVE IN STORE FOR US?
BUT AS SOMEONE SAID TO ME LAST
YEAR IN RESPONSE TO A DAYS
REFLECTION.
REVEREND HATE IS NEVER THE WAY.
WE KNOW THIS.
HATE IS NEVER THE WAY.
SO ALSO MUST BE NEVER GIVE IN TO
DESPAIR.
WHATEVER CHANGES MAY COME.
WITH OUR HEARTS HOPEFUL IN OUR
MINDS OPEN. WE CAN MAKE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
A YEAR OF GROWTH.
ACCEPTANCE
AND UNDERSTANDING.
NOW MORE MEDIA.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE S. ORGASM
VISITORS REMAIN STANDING. AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN US SOME REALLY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA. AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MR KALRA.
COLLEAGUES IN GAS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN THE PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
MISSION.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO MONDAY NOVEMBER
TWENTY SEVENTH TWENTY SEVENTEEN
PERCENT TO THE PROVISIONS OF
GENERAL FIFTY NINE THE FOLLOWING
ASSEMBLY JOURNAL FOR THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN REGULAR
SESSION WAS PRINTED ALL THE
ASSEMBLY WAS AN INTERIM STUDY
RECESS.
TROUBLING COMMUNICATION WAS
PREMATURE CALDERONE MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS.
THAT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS ARE PETITIONS
THERE ARE NINE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED A RAT IN AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR.
THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
MOVING TWO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCE IS FOR
THE DAY.
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ADAM GRAY.
FOR L. THIS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS JIM
COOPER.
ADRIN IS AREA AND MARK STONE.
CORRECTION MR HIS ARYAN IS HERE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARC STONE FOR
ILLNESS.
AND FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY.
ACRE.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS MISTER CALLED
AROUND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SPEND ASSEMBLY WILL FORTY FIVE
POINT.
AND ALLOW THE PRESIDING.
SPEAK ON.
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE LIKE YOU MISTER SPEAKER
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY WILL NINETY
SEVEN ARE REQUESTING ANIMUS
CONSENSUALLY WERE FOR AYE TO
MEDIATE. AS THE ONE ON NINE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SO SHALL BE
THE ORDER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
WILL NINETY SIX A REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE LOW FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO
THE BUSINESS. AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE BILLS FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE AND REFER THEM TO
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE SP NINETY
THREE. SB ONE FOURTEEN SP ONE
FIFTEEN SB ONE SIXTEEN S. B. ONE
EIGHTEEN SQ ONE NINETEEN THAT'S
THE ONE TWENTY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
RETURN ITEM ONE AB ONE SIX
EXCEL IS FOR THE SENATE.
AGAIN WITH THAT OBJECTION.
SUCH SHALL BE THAT ORDER.
MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE.
WELL ITEMS SEVENTY NINE THROUGH
EIGHTY FOUR PASS AND RETAIN WERE
MOVING TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
FIVE AC R. ONE THIRTY FOUR.
BY MISTER EDUARDO GARCIA.
MEMBERS.
MISTER C. ARE YOU READY TO
PROCEED WITH THIS ITEM.
WE'LL PASS TEMPORARILY.
FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY SIX
IN EIGHTY SEVEN. PASS AND
RETAIN.
BUT WE'VE ALREADY REFERRED.
FILE AND MEDIATE SP ONE OH NINE.
FILE ITEMS EIGHTY NINE AND
NINETY.
PASS AND RETAIN
MEMBERS. WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
UP THAT THIRD READING ITEM.
A LITTLE BIT LATER IN THE
SESSION BUT MEMBERS IF I COULD
PLEASE HAVE YOUR ATTENTION.
AND MEMBERS AYE LIKE ASK YOU
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
WE COULD HAVE YOUR ATTENTION
MEMBERS.
THE STATE ASSEMBLY.
WILL BE MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
AND THE GERMANSAND MEMORY.
THE STATE ASSEMBLY. ONE NOW
MEMORIALIZE THE VICTIMS.
OF THE HORRIFIC SHOOTING.
THAT OCCURRED ON OCTOBER FIRST
IN LAS VEGAS NEVADA.
THIRTY FIVE OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
VICTIMS.
WERE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IN LOS VEGAS TO SIMPLY ENJOY A
NIGHT OF MUSIC WITH FRIENDS.
IN FAMILY.
THESE VICTIMS WERE CONSTITUENTS.
TWENTY ONE.
OF OUR ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES.
SADLY.
ONCE AGAIN WE ARE FACED WITH
HAVING TO RECKON WITH THE
SENSELESSNESS OF A COWARD'S
ACTIONS.
AND NATIONAL INACTION IN THE
WAKE OF A TRAGEDY.
CLERK WILL NOW READ.
THIRTY FIVE NAMES AND CITIES.
THE CALIFORNIA VICTIMS.
SUSAN SMITH.
SEAMY VALLEY.
JOHN HAD BEEN.
CLARITA.
GARY BARNETT.
GUARDING GROW.
CANDACE BOWERS GUARDING GROWTH.
VICTOR LINK LISA VALLEJO.
THOMAS STAGE JUNIOR CORONA.
CHRISTOPHER LEWIS WHITE BALL.
CORONA.
THE COG AND RACHA.
EAST BELL.
THREE CYNICAL CAMERA.
SENCHA.
JACK REGINALD BE IN JUNIOR
BAKERSFIELD.
BAILEY SCHWEITZER.
KELSEY MEADOWS TASK.
KURT BONTA HELLO KEVIN PARK.
JENNIFER TOPAZ IRVINE SAN DIEGO.
AND YOUR BECAUSE DHEA. HANGS IN
BEACH.
JORDAN RIVERA LAVERNE.
LIEUTENANT DEREK BOWE TAYLOR
OXNARD.
KERRY LEN GALLIVAN.
THOUSAND OAKS.
CHRIS HE'S IN CALM CAMERINO.
MELISSA RAMIREZ.
LITTLE ROCK.
JENNIFER MARIE PARKS
LANG CASTER.
STACEY EDGWARE NEVADO.
DENISE CO HEN. CARPINTERIA.
HANNAH CALLERS. BEAUMONT.
AUSTIN DAVIS.
RIVERSIDE.
ANGELA ANGIE GOMEZ RIVERSIDE.
PATRICIA PATTIE MESSED US
MENIFEE.
SANDY CASEY MANHATTAN BEACH.
RACHEL PARKER MANHATTAN BEACH.
CRISTIANO MADE YOUR DAY
TORRANCE.
LISA PATTERSON. LOMITA.
BRIAN FRAZIER LA PALMA.
DINA GARDNER GRAND TERRACE.
AUSTIN MEYER MARINA.
AND MICHELLE THOUGH EAGLE ROCK.
MEMBERS PLEASE STAND AS WE
OBSERVE A MOMENT OF SILENCE.
TO HONOR THE VICTIMS
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK. TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
TAKING UP FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTY FIVE THAT'S ACR ONE
THIRTY FOR THE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE THIRTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO GAIN
AWARENESS AND PREVENTION MONTH.
MR GARCIA EMAIL BUT MISTER
SPEAKER IN COLLEAGUES HAPPY NEW
YEAR IT'S WITH GREAT HONOR THAT
I GET TO PRESENT ACR. ONE THIRTY
FOUR.
HE SEAT ARE ONE THIRTY FOUR IS
GANG AWARENESS. AND PREVENTION
MONTH HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. PUNE THIS RESOLUTION
DESIGNATES THE MONTH OF JANUARY
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IS GOING
AWARENESS AND PREVENTION MONTH
IN CALIFORNIA. AND ENCOURAGES
CITIES AND CONSTITUENTS ACROSS
THE STATE POSER OBSERVE THIS
MONTH WITH APPROPRIATE PROGRAMS
CEREMONIES AND ACTIVITIES TO
PREVENT FUTURE GANG ACTIVITY AND
HONOR THOSE WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
LIVES DUE TO GANG.
VIOLENCE
SPECIFICALLY THIS RESOLUTION
MAKES THE FOLLOWING LEGISLATIVE
FINDINGS.
GANG VIOLENCE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
AN AVERAGE OF TWO THOUSAND GANG
RELATED HOMICIDES EACH YEAR.
ACCORDING TO THE DATA PROVIDED
BY THE NATIONAL YOUTH GANG
CENTER.
CALIFORNIANS MUST WORK TOGETHER
TO ENSURE FIRST RESPONDERS DO
NOT HAVE TO RESPOND TO CRIME
SCENES AND DYING VICTIMS IN
DANGER SURROUNDINGS WHERE THEY
CAN BECOME THE NEXT TARGETS.
LOCAL COMMUNITIES NEED TO LEARN
AND UNDERSTAND THAT GANG
AFFILIATION AND ACTIVITY IS
PREVENTABLE.
THE SOLUTION TO GANG VIOLENCE IS
WITHIN EVERY CALIFORNIAN.
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE WILL
COURAGE AND INNER STRENGTH TO
STAND UP TO THEIR MORAL
OBLIGATION AS A CITIZEN OF THEIR
COMMUNITY. TO HELP BY THE
TEARING OUR YOUTH AND THEIR
FAMILIES FROM VIOLENCE BY
EDUCATING THEM ON HOW TO FORM
STRONGER FAMILY BONDS.
THEY'RE IN THE HOUSEHOLD AND IN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
AN ORGANIZATION IN OUR DISTRICT.
MOTHERS AND MAN AGAINST GANG
VIOLENCE IS A COALITION THE
PERFECT EXAMPLE. OF AN
ORGANIZATION THAT IS WORKING
TIRELESSLY HARD TO PREVENT THIS
GANG ACTIVITY. AND MAKING SURE
THAT NO FAMILY HAS TO SUFFER THE
LOSS OF LIFE.
MEMBERS.
THIS RESOLUTION.
AND THE IDEA CAME TO US VIA A
FAMILY.
FAMILY BY THE NAME OF YOU NEED
AND MIGHT THINK CARS THAT WHO
ARE FROM IMPERIAL COUNTY.
UNFORTUNATELY YOU NEED AND MY
THE THEME.
LOST THEIR SON.
A VERY TALENTED YOUNG MAN WHO
WAS IN HIS SENIOR YEAR OF HIGH
SCHOOL.
FOOTBALL STAR LIKED BY EVERYONE.
OLDER BROTHER TWO SISTERS MY
GOOD FRIEND. BUT TO THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY A YOUNG MAN WITH A
BRIGHT FUTURE.
WHO UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO A GANG
MEMBER? LOST HIS LIFE SENSIBLY.
AND.
YOU NEEDN'T THE MOTHER OF MY
BEAN AND THE FATHER.
SAID. YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT GOING
TO LET THE LOSS OF OUR SON BE IN
VAIN.
AND SO THEY'VE MADE IT THEIR
MISSION SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN.
I THEY'VE ESTABLISHED AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED THE.
MOTHERS AND MEN.
AGAINST GANG VIOLENCE.
AND THEIR MISSION IS TO. IT
EDUCATE.
EVERY PARENT
WORK WITH OUR SCHOOLS ARE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY. AND NOW BEGIN TO
EXPAND THEIR SPHERE.
OF INFLUENCE AS IT RELATES TO
THEM TELLING THEIR STORY.
AND DOT I BRING THIS RESOLUTION
TO YOU HUMBLY BECAUSE IT IS
SOMETHING THAT STEMS FROM.
OUR DISTRICT.
BUT EVERY YEAR IN JANUARY YOU NO
WE COMMIT OURSELVES TO NEW
YEAR'S RESOLUTIONS.
WHETHER IT BE I'M GOING TO
EXERCISE MORE I'M GOING TO DO
MORE OF THIS OR LESS OF THAT.
AND SO TODAY I ASK THAT.
JANUARY IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE
RECOMMIT OURSELVES.
TO THE ISSUE OF GANG VIOLENCE
AWARENESS PREVENTION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK UP FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON ACR.
ONE THIRTY FOUR AND DOT AGAIN
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
ATTENTION ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MR GARCIA WOULD YOU
LIKE CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTIONS R. YES I
WOULD ASK THAT THE FIRST CALL BE
OPEN FOR COOPER'S.
THANK YOU.
THINGS GARCIA DOCTOR WEBER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
YES MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I.
I APPLAUD MY COLLEAGUE.
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA FOR A
BRING THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD
T'S A VERY IMPORTANT RESOLUTION
AND I THINK WE'VE DONE A NUMBER
OF THINGS ON THIS FLOOR TO IN
TERMS OF SOCIAL JUSTICE TO TALK
ABOUT GANGS AND. AND LIST AND
ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS BUT
ONE OF THINGS I THINK WE ALL
AGREE UPON IS THAT NO COMMUNITY
SHOULD EVER BE IN IN CONTROL OF
BY GANGS. NO COMPLETELY SHOULD
EVER FEEL A SENSE OF LOSS AND
AND HOPELESSNESS BECAUSE OF THE
GANGS IN THEIR COMMUNITY. I
THINK WE'VE ALL BEEN AFFECTED BY
GANG VIOLENCE WE'VE ALL HAD THE
THE FRIENDS OR FAMILY SO
CONSTITUENTS WHO LOST THEIR
LIVES ARE WHO'VE EITHER JUST
BEEN INTIMIDATED. BY THE GANG
VIOLENCE THAT EXISTS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES BUT I THINK ONE OF
THE THINGS WE'VE LEARNED AND
I'VE WORKED WITH A LOT OF GANG
UGH ARE ANTI GAY GROUPS AS WELL
AS FORMER GANG MEMBERS. ONE OF
THE THINGS I'VE LEARNED OVER THE
YEARS IS THAT GANG GANG VIOLENCE
AND GANG ACTIVITY IS
PREVENTABLE.
IT IT STANDS VERY EARLY IN LIFE
FROM A NOT HAVING THAT SCHOOLS
THAT ARE SUPPORTIVE. NOT HAVING
FAMILIES THAT ARE SUPPORTIVE
HAVING FAMILIES TO WORK SO MANY
HOURS EVERY DAY THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE THE TIME AND ENERGY TO
INVEST IN THEIR CHILDREN. NOT
HAVING THE KIND OF PARK AND
RECREATION PROGRAMS THAT NURTURE
AND CARE FOR CHILDREN SO WE KNOW
THAT IT IS PREVENTABLE. THAT WE
CAN SAVE A LOT OF LIVES AND WE
CAN SAVE A LOT OF MONEY WITH
REGARDS TO BASICALLY SIMPLY
INVESTING IN YOUNG PEOPLE EARLY
ENOUGH. TO HELP TO PREVENT THAT
THE STRENGTHENING OUR FAMILIES
AND GIVING THEM AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BASICALLY BE THE FAMILIES
THEY WANT TO BE WHICH IS TO
SUPPORT IT NURTURE OUR CHILDREN.
WE'VE LEARNED THAT A LOT OF LOVE
IT LLOYD MORE INCARCERATION. OF
MORE VIOLENCE DOESN'T IN THAT IN
ESSENCE DOES NOT SOLVE THE
PROBLEM. I'VE SEEN IN MY OWN
COMMUNITY WHERE WITH IT'S A
CYCLE WHERE. WE HAVE SOME GANG
INTERVENTION AND WE ROUND UP ALL
THE GANG MEMBERS WE PUT HIM IN
JAIL FOR A CERTAIN PERIOD OF
TIME AND THEN YOU SIDE FIND THE
GANG VIOLENCE STARTS AGAIN. AND
I ASK THE QUESTION WHY DID IT
START AGAIN WHAT'S WHAT'S GOING
ON A SAID WELL ALL THE GANG
MEMBERS JUST GOT OUT OF JAIL.
AND SO IT BEGINS AGAIN AND SO WE
HAVE DONE VERY LITTLE NOT ONLY
IN OUR COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO WHEN
THOSE WERE PART CAR SERRATED TO
BASICALLY BEGAN TO THE LEVEL OF
INTERVENTION THERE. SO IT IS
PREVENTABLE AND WE AS AS A AS A
CALIFORNIANS NEED TO LOOK AT
THIS VERY CAREFULLY RATHER THAN
RUNNING AWAY FROM IT. WE NEED TO
EMBRACE IT. ISIS SAY TO MY
COMMUNITIES WHEN. WHEN THEY WILL
TALK COUSINS EASE OF THE PEOPLE
NEXT
DOOR. WE HAVE TO BEGIN TO
EMBRACE THEM AND HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
OPPORTUNITY THERE IS HOPE
THERE'S A CHANCE FOR GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT RATHER THAN RUNNING
AWAY. THESE ARE CHILDREN WHO
WOULD TWO AND THREE IS ALL THAT
WE SHOULD HAVE EMBRACED EARLY IN
LIFE SO THEY COULD SEEK US SO I
ENCOURAGE ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
IN THE FAMILIES WHO OUT THERE
WORKING SO HARD. ON THIS TO
CONTINUE THE WORK FOR US TO DO
WHAT WE CAN IN TERMS OF
RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE GANG INTERVENTION PROGRAMS.
THAT ARE ADEQUATELY FUNDED IN
OUR COMMUNITIES NOT JUST BECAUSE
WE FEEL GOOD ABOUT IT BUT
BECAUSE IT SAVES LIVES AND IT
ENSURES THE CALIFORNIA BECOMES A
STRONG STATE THAT WE CAN BE
PROUD OF. I WANNA THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FOR THIS AYE I'LL ASK
ALL OF YOU TO BOTH ACR ONE
THIRTY FOUR BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
TO BEGIN TO LOOK AT YOUR OWN
COMMUNITIES AND FIND OUT HOW YOU
CAN BE ENGAGED.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
MR GARCIA YOU MAY CLOSE ON THE
RESOLUTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO WHO I
THINK. ARTICULATE EXACTLY.
WHAT THE PURPOSE OF THIS
RESOLUTION IS?
IN OUR COMMUNITIES THERE'S WAYS
THAT WE DEAL WITH. THE VIOLENCE
THAT OCCURS IT WHETHER IT'S IN A
BLUNT FORCE MEANT.
TACTICS
BUT I THINK WE ALSO HEARD JUST
NOW THAT THERE ARE WAYS TO
INVEST AND PREVENT.
IN HAVING TO SPEND ALL THAT
MONEY.
ON THE REPRESSIVE APPROACH YOU
KNOW TO THESE PROBLEMS IN OUR
COMMUNITY SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
AGAIN. FOR HER COMMENTS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK US THAT THE
FIRST THAT ROLE BE OPEN FOR
COOPERS.
THINGS GARCIA.
WITHOUT.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS
COAUTHORS.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY
TWO CO AUTHORS ADDED.
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MR GARCIA I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
GUESTS RELATIVE TO THIS
RESOLUTION YOU ARE ONCE AGAIN
RECOGNIZE SOME BEFORE THE
ASSEMBLY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER IF I MAY GET UP. OUR
COLLEAGUES ATTENTION TO THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER. A WITH US FROM
IMPERIAL COUNTY ARE THE
FOUNDERS.
AND THE PARENTS OF NOT BEING
AVAILABLE.
GARZA.
WHO FOUNDED A MOTHER'S AND MEN?
AGAINST A GANG VIOLENCE LET ME
SHARE WITH YOU A A TINY STORY IS
THAT. YOU LEAVE STARTED THE
ORGANIZATION AS MOTHERS AGAINST
GANG VIOLENCE AND.
YOU KNOW LIKE I'M ANY FAMILY
RIGHT.
WE HAVE
WELL PARTNERS.
AND THE IN THAT FAMILY YOU KNOW
WE WE. AS PARTNERS WE WE DO
THINGS TOGETHER IN SO MUCH PAIN.
IN HER HUSBAND'S AT IT WHAT
ABOUT ME.
WHAT ABOUT ME IS IT JUST MOTHERS
AGAINST GANG VIOLENCE WAS THEIR
MOTHERS AND FATHERS AND MEN?
AND I THINK I TO THE MAN AND
HOW.
THIS CHAMBER YOU KNOW WE AS MEN
AS FATHERS.
TWO YOUNG MAN OR TWO YOUNG
DAUGHTERS HAVE RESPONSIBILITY.
OUGHT TO TEACH YOU KNOW WHETHER
BE OUR YOUNG BOYS ABOUT VIOLENCE
WHETHER BE GANG VIOLENCE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHATEVER IT
MAY BE WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
IN SO MUCH BEING. SAID THAT THIS
IS AN ORGANIZATION THAT SHOULD
BE MOTHERS IN MEN AGAINST GANG
VIOLENCE AND SO I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND THANK. THEM
FOR BEING HERE ALL THE WAY FROM
IMPERIAL COUNTY AS THE FOUNDERS
OF THIS ORGANIZATION AND THOSE
WHO. SAID THAT THE LOSS OF OUR
SON. WILL NOT BE IN VAIN AND
THAT WE WILL GO OUT.
AT MAKING SURE THAT WE DO WHAT
WE CAN TO EDUCATE AND PREVENT.
YOU KNOW FROM THIS TRAGIC
SITUATION OCCURRING AGAIN AND
ALTHOUGH YOU KNOW WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO BUT THEY ARE ON A
MISSION. AND IT'S NOW NOT JUST
IN IMPERIAL COUNTY MISSION BUT A
STATE OF CALIFORNIA MISSION AS
WELL PLEASE HELP ME WELCOME YOU
LEóN MY TEAM. OF WHO ARE HERE
AND BOARD MEMBER CHRISTIAN I
KNEW YES FROM THE ORGANIZATION
MOTHERS AND MEN AGAINST.
VIOLENCE
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS JUST A
BRIEF ANNOUNCEMENT.
I BELIEVE THAT YESTERDAY WAS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DANTE A COST IS
BIRTHDAY IS THAT CORRECT SIR.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ACOSTA.
AND ALSO YESTERDAY ASSEMBLYWOMAN
JACKIE IRWIN HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
THE SESSION THAT THE SCHEDULE IS
AS FOLLOWS.
FRIDAY JANUARY FIFTH NO FLOOR
SESSION NO CHECKING SESSION
MONDAY JANUARY EIGHTH FLOOR
SESSION IS AT ONE PM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WE
PASS RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISS YOUR CALL THEIR OWN MOVES
AND MISTER DALLI SECONDS.
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY JANUARY EIGHTH AT
ONE PM IN THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED